less than y equal 1 over X okay so I can
write the Y or DX equals and then I'm
going to introduce my limit notation
just like I had here so I'm going to
take a limit as H approaches 0
now I'm deliberately doing this
differently visit this morning because I
can't right now just recite if why can't
I just write that as it is on the right
hand side so X 0 X right so if I wanted
to do that I would have to say let that
be f of X and then I could use this
notation but I don't mean to it's cool
I've written down the definition now I'm
just going to apply it to this guy okay
what is what what am I going to get for
this when I put in X space into the
function it'll be 1 over X potato and
just start to see the explanation
wherever I saw X so that's 1 again on
the new version ok that's the first bit
I'm also going to take away if X which
in this case is should say why
ok cooler than I don't have enough um
the denominator is always the same it
just stays H ok now in previous
questions in the exertion were doing
earlier all you basically had to do was
expand whatever thing you had over here
you have a square or a cubic or even a
power 4 if you got to that question you
just extend all out stuff cancels
there's nothing to explain to you some
what would you like me to do is set
I have two fractions maybe I should just
subtract them what will I need to do in
order to subtract them what do I need
between the two factions I need a copy
that our data right I'm going to write
no limit why am I writing the limit
again because I want the tangent not the
secant okay the cupboard under it is
kind of useful to me ears x times X plus
h like that what am I going to get on
the numerator so this thing will turn
into nx7
and this will turn into an x plus h as a
look can I can I do fractions that's
okay I could divide that whole thing by
H but I hate line fractional fractions
because it's just messy so I'm just
going to write it like that it's just a
bit of more concise are you happy so far
okay while I'm at it I'm also going to
point out just like I've shown over here
right this is p1 DX then I'm calculating
at that I'm evaluating that's the on DX
of Y but I know what what is is this so
this is another way again this is how
you use this differential operator you
see I'm applying it to this function
okay so these all mean the same thing on
the left hand side just like the your
meter said in the record okay do you
write ND yes
no one comes to the x-squared a little
bit later on it does be something but
not that so that's why I'm writing as
two separate fact it is operator to
operator
so if doing something that is it's not
simply multiplying across will come to
that a little bit a bit of time consult
I'll be simplify this fraction that I
guess you what I got
yeah well good which leaves you is you
is H on what would the edge miles a good
- arms Oh yep the denominator hadn't
changed Heather yeah like relocated page
of this salient if you put x times 80
times in footage and it goes of you wait
are you talking about this edge here
okay I'm going to write that down as a
separate thing over here one of the
reasons why is because when you're doing
these questions later on like this
process you will actually get to leave
behind which is nice because it is quite
long and drawn-out so in this particular
time when we do want you to pay
attention to the process it's really
important you have every line there you
don't get too much often will actually
give you the derivative and we don't
watch it actually like getting the
answer is not the point we want to see
you understand the machinery that gets
you there okay so it tends to be not be
careful now I am ready to cancel having
evaluated numerator so that leaves me
with the limit as H approaches zero of
what this is one over
how does items that look okay at this
point I can actually do I can actually
see what happens when a to really get to
zero which I couldn't do before
right the tops just going to be negative
one
don't you get that one just get x
squared right x times X plus zero so lo
and behold we have an answer here but I
wanted to think what does this answer me
King papi just draw like a rock what
address that just draw it the size here
doesn't have to be huge
get the idea okay now remember what it
is that we just found out remember one
of you that we just found out this
apparently is a great function the
derivative of this guy over here honey
well let's just touch down a dime let's
just add value so I can say when x
equals give me a number
sure when x equals four okay what the
derivative is going to be equal to I'm
just going to evaluate it can be minus 1
over 4 squared which in this case is 16
now tell me tell me how would you
describe a line with agrees of minus 1
over 6 K was the -2 decreasing
decreasing what about the 1 over 16 what
does that tell you really is small which
means shallow right which makes sense
because where when X when X equal 4 be
somewhere over here right and you can
see of course it's very shallow and as X
gets bigger and bigger what happens to
the gradient the gradient it's smaller
as well it gets closer to 0
of course it does because what does
approaching is approaching an asymptote
right we have a small value of x what
about a small value of x say x equals 1
remember 100 x equals 1 over 100 in this
case what will distribute
so let's just today this means you've
got a minus one on the top and then on
the bottom you've got one over 100
square right what do I do if it's what
if it's me the baby is not going
anywhere but this is a fraction on a
fraction right you're taking the
reciprocal so I'm pretty sure that's
negative 100 squared isn't it negative
10,000 does that make sense what does
that mean
negative it's still decreasing in fact
you sit among you will avert us it's
always decreasing there's no value of
that you could put in here to change the
side of this so it's always decreasing
and this is really seat right of course
it's steep because why why is it so
steep because again it's approaching it
as interpret the different kind asset oh
just vertical here which is why if I
went close request request side I'm
going to get the really steep gradient
you can see lastly why is it negative
all the time right let me put in
negative values over here this is
decreasing and this is decreasing does
it make sense